This video is sponsored by Brilliant.
Start learning for free with the link in the
description and the first 200 get 20% off
the annual premium subscription.
In the early 1980s, Britain began discussing
with China the future of its last remaining
major colony, Hong Kong.
Immediately, Beijing made clear, in no uncertain
terms, that it would neither accept an independent
Hong Kong, nor a Chinese one administered
by Britain.
Instead, it suggested an alternative: a temporary,
50-year limbo as a separate, Special Administrative
Region of the PRC.
This new, never-before-tried proposal raised
many questions, from the trivial to the existential:
What flag would be flown?
What currency would be used?
Which citizenship would they hold?
And how much of Britain’s presence would
remain?
With no guiding historical precedent with
which to refer, as its neighbor Macau had
yet to be handed over by Portugal, the answers
to these questions were wide open.
Legally, only the New Territories were leased,
set to expire after 99-years in 1997.
The geographically smaller but well-developed
Hong Kong Island and Kowloon Peninsula had
been surrendered in perpetuity.
Initially, the British considered retaining
their rightful territory to become a small,
independent state.
And, as proof of just how wide open the possibilities,
there was even a slightly-serious proposal
to resettle its 5 million inhabitants in Northern
Ireland.
Beijing, however, soon reminded Britain that
the island received its water and supplies
from the mainland, whose pipes could easily
be shut off.
Thus, at least one question was answered:
All of Hong Kong would become Chinese soil
when the lease expired in ‘97.
Of those remaining, that of citizenship - something
at the very heart of identity - proved to
be especially significant and contentious.
Until the 1960s, all British Nationals - whether
born on the British isles or one of its overseas
colonies, like Hong Kong, were permitted to
enter and stay in the UK as full, unrestricted
citizens.
As its empire began unwinding in the 60s and
70s, however, it feared an influx of immigrants
from its African and Asian colonies.
New laws were passed making it more difficult
for these groups to enter unless they or their
families were, quote, ‘connected’ to the
UK.
In 1981 The British Nationality Act created
three new categories: British Citizens, for
residents of the UK, British Overseas Citizens,
and, for Hong Kong and other Crown colonies,
British Dependent Territories Citizens.
With this law, ‘British citizenship’ was
fundamentally redefined to exclude millions
of overseas ‘citizens’ from the ‘right
to abode’ - the ability to enter and stay
in the UK, at will, and without restriction.
From then on, Hong Kongers were relegated
to a new form of literal ‘second-class citizenship’
in a thinly-veiled attempt to stop non-white
immigration to the UK.
And while this change was not solely-aimed
at them, it affected the territory in a very
unique way.
While citizens of other colonies lost their
right to abode as they gained that of their
new, independent country, those in Hong Kong
were to be handed over to an existing country
whose commitments had not yet been tested.
In the eyes of locals, Britain had betrayed
them - a feeling which would only intensify
as the years went on.
Because the city would soon no longer be a
British dependent territory, a new status
was created specifically for its special circumstance,
called the British National (Overseas) Passport.
It, like its predecessor, lacked the right
to abode in the UK but could only be applied
for before the handover.
The Chinese, though, refused to accept the
embarrassing idea that Hong Kongers would
remain British Nationals, of any kind, after
‘97.
China insisted that, at midnight on the day
of the handover, all would lose their British
status and instantly become Chinese Nationals.
Their old passports could be used as travel
documents, but not as proof of British citizenship.
Then, in 1989 the tanks of the People’s
Liberation Army rolled into Tiananmen Square,
and the slowly-growing collective unease felt
in Hong Kong, reaching a tipping point.
A million stunned citizens took to the streets,
whose fear of uncertainty had become, simply,
fear.
But, there was still some hope.
Luckily, the British position was far from
singular.
The local Hong Kong government, led by its
last governor, Chris Patten, felt this rising
tension and lobbied Britain on their behalf.
London expressed fear that if it gave the
BN(O) right to abode, 3 million immigrants
might suddenly flood the UK, overwhelming
its social system.
This, despite the fact that 30 million white
commonwealth citizens in Australia, Canada,
and New Zealand also could’ve immigrated
at any given time.
It would be wrong, they said, to promise the
right to abode if they could not fulfill these
obligations in the event of an emergency.
They also argued doing so would violate its
Joint Declaration with China, the document
basis for the handover.
And yet, 10 months later, Britain did just
that.
The British Nationality Selection Scheme gave
full British citizenship to 50,000 hand-picked
residents, along with their spouse and children
under 18.
This elite group was chosen directly by the
governor and was based on four categories
of people - including professionals and civil
servants.
Selection was based primarily on a point system,
which rewarded, among other things, English
proficiency and ‘connections’ to the UK.
Those not deemed important or ‘British’
enough by their colonizers were simply out
of luck.
Still, knowing of these inadequacies, Patten
continued lobbying, increasingly finding himself
caught between locals and officials in Britain.
Ironically, both sides made the same accusation:
Locals suggested not giving the right to abode
was a sign Britain must not be confident in
Hong Kong’s post-handover prospects, if
it genuinely feared a mass exodus.
At the same time, Britain argued that giving
the right to abode was a sign Patten wasn’t
confident in his negotiations with China,
since otherwise it wouldn’t be necessary.
Amidst this larger debacle, Lord Patten also
fought to resolve two unusual complications…
First, Chinese Law stated that only ethnically-Chinese
Hong Kongers would automatically become Chinese
Nationals at the time of the handover.
But, the BN(O) passport was acquired by application,
meaning that, if one were not ethnically-Chinese
and did not apply for the BN(O) passport,
at the time of the handover, their Dependent
Territory Citizenship status would expire
but the Chinese would refuse to naturalize
them, leaving them, effectively, stateless.
One Indian family, in particular, had lived
in British Hong Kong for 60-years, received
British educations, spoke with British accents,
and yet, only some were granted full British
citizenship while their brothers and sisters
were not.
Even after learning of these circumstances,
the British Home Office held the position
for years that they would simply become British
Overseas Citizens and that if they were indeed
forced out of Hong Kong, Britain would then
consider them for immigration.
Only in the last year before the handover
did Britain finally acquiesce.
Second, was the question of visas.
A new Special Administrative Region passport
would be created for after the handover, featuring
the same national emblem and illustration
of the Great Wall as that of the mainland.
The question was whether its holders would
be given visa-free access to the UK.
Here, too, the British Home Office pushed
back, suggesting anti-immigration voters would
make no distinction between the right to abode
and visa-free access.
Patten, in turn, countered that not doing
so would infuriate the Chinese, who would
lobby for fewer rights for the BN(O) passport,
making it even less valuable.
Hong Kong would also likely impose visa restrictions
on its 400,000 annual British visitors.
After much back-and-forth, Beijing assured
them that the SAR passport would only be available
to holders of permanent Hong Kong ID cards,
only in Hong Kong, and only by Hong Kong immigration
authorities.
6-month visa-free access was secured, and
the Prime Minister announced “We in Britain
will have continuing responsibilities to the
people of Hong Kong…[and] will be watching
to see that the letter and spirit of the Joint
Declaration are honoured, now, next year and
for fifty years beyond.”
- words deliberately chosen to prevent any
future British politician from reneging, or,
at least, to make a fool of anyone who tried.
These two rare successes in the long, drawn-out
leadup to the handover were celebrated but
still left what many considered the largest
source of unease: the status of the BN(O)
passport.
This tension became palpable in the final
months before the handover as tens of thousands
stood in line to register for the British
passport 24-hours before the deadline.
Finally, the day came.
On July 1st, 1997, after nearly two decades
of negotiations, vague promises, worry, and
skepticism, Hong Kong became China.
Citizenship, however, always remained contentious,
and, in the eyes of many, an unforgivable
black mark on Britain’s legacy.
It has even since been revealed that Britain
asked Portugal not to give full citizenship
to Macau residents, which would make it look
bad in comparison.
Some renounced their British citizenship in
a pledge of support to China.
Others lost credibility for holding foreign
passports, which some said undermined their
claims of loyalty.
Over time, the BN(O) passport, once seen as
a valuable insurance policy, became more of
an expensive piece of paper.
Compared to the Hong Kong SAR passport, it’s
three times as costly, offers 48 fewer visa-free
countries and territories, and, perhaps most
embarrassing, is less useful when entering
the UK.
While Hong Kong passports allow expedited
immigration, holders of the BN(O) fill out
landing cards and enter the UK like any other
foreigner.
They also can’t apply for Australian visas
online and are banned from becoming Chief
Executive.
Most of its holders will never have use for
its few benefits like the right to join the
British armed forces and get married under
British law.
And, as one final nail in the coffin, because
China views the BN(O) as merely a travel document,
it does not allow its holders British consular
access anywhere on Chinese soil - whether
on the mainland, Macau, or Hong Kong.
In practice, the BN(O) is similar to the status
of those born in American Samoa to non-U.S.
citizen parents.
Despite being on American soil, such a person
is regarded as a U.S. National but not a U.S.
Citizen - and thus not allowed to vote, serve
on a jury, or apply for restricted government
jobs.
Although, unlike BN(O) holders, they do have
the right to reside in any part of the country.
That is, until, possibly, now.
After Beijing announced a National Security
Bill which will outlaw “secession, subversion,
and terrorism” against the Chinese National
government in Hong Kong, Britain responded
that it’s now, 23 years later, ‘reconsidering’
the rights of BN(O) passports.
So far, it’s offered to extend visa-free
stays from six to extendable-periods of twelve
months, allowing for work and study, and creating
a path for citizenship.
Although this applies to all roughly 3-million
holders of the passport, whether or not they’re
currently renewed, as well as their dependents,
it leaves out the majority of its population.
Given that the BN(O) could only be applied
for before 1997 and can’t be passed down,
those under 23 - a large swath of Hong Kong’s
protestors - will likely be ineligible.
Many details are yet unknown: Will these rights
be extended to all residents?
What, exactly, will be the criteria for permanent
citizenship?
And how will China retaliate?
In the absence of any answers to these questions,
many see Britain’s offer as more political
than practical.
In truth, the right to abode was always misunderstood
as a debate about immigration, when, in fact,
it was one of confidence.
Rather than encourage migration, it was always
intended to prevent it.
Patten knew the health of Hong Kong’s bureaucracy
would be left in the hands of a relatively
small number of highly-educated, well-off
individuals.
The right to abode was about instilling the
confidence necessary to keep them in Hong
Kong after the handover - along with their
democratic ideals.
It would also act as a check on Beijing - the
knowledge that it may lose the city’s most
talented if it did not keep them satisfied.
Indeed, famously, in the years before the
handover, hundreds of thousands of Hong Kongers
fled to Canada, Australia, the U.S., U.K.,
and elsewhere.
Their reasons, however, are largely misunderstood.
Some, of course, stayed abroad - where they
established Cantonese as the language of Chinatowns.
Many, on the other hand, stayed only long
enough to gain citizenship, before returning
to Hong Kong with this new insurance plan.
This is so common, in fact, it has a name:
“The return tide of Hong Kong”.
An estimated 35% of those who left in the
80s returned later.
Another - ‘Astronaut’ refers to one family
member - usually the father - who stayed,
making money in Hong Kong while the rest of
the family lived abroad - in Vancouver, Sydney,
San Francisco, or elsewhere - to gain citizenship.
Such is the predicament of Hong Kongers - they
love their city, their language, and their
way of life.
They want, above all else, and as long as
possible, to stay.
And yet, they also know these things are temporary.
Now, just as foreign passports act as a sort
of insurance plan for Hong Kongers, a strong
understanding of math, science, and especially
computer science, is the universal insurance
plan that can help you earn better grades,
get better jobs, and ride out recessions like
the one we’re currently in.
Brilliant holds the philosophy that most of
these topics are really best learned a little
bit at a time, every day, over weeks or months.
It takes big topics Cryptocurrency, Solar
Energy, and Vector Calculus, breaks them down
into small interactive exercises, and explains
them in a way that actually makes sense.
Brilliant gives you a new puzzle or problem
to solve every day on its beautifully-made
mobile app and website, where you can also
ask questions, discuss solutions, and dive
deeper into whatever topic interests you most.
Start learning today for free with the link
in the description.
The first 200 people will also get 20% off
the annual premium subscription.